dies doch nicht ziehen
[Musik]
alternativ gibt es nicht möchte ein
video moment mal kurz ein bisschen
gucken hier erst ein mega mega fete
sorry weil ich glaube kam fünf teil
keine videos ich weiß jahres in letzter
zeit abgesagt wie habt ihr das zu wenig
kommt aber ich habe 60 diese woche noch
einmal die letzten zwei klausuren
geschrieben das war mega wichtig und ich
konnte mich halten und darauf
konzentrieren damit eine gute note
streifen nicht nochmals einen muss man
deswegen kann man halt jetzt die ganze
woche keine videos aber jetzt ist das
vorbei und ich kann euch versichern zu
100 prozent
jetzt kommen mega mega viele videos ich
glaube viele videos die jetzt kommen
sind noch nie gekommen innerhalb von den
nächsten drei wochen oder so also ich
versuche wirklich jeden tag ein video zu
produzieren ich glaube nicht dass es
jeden tag ist knapp aber bestimmt
fünfmal die woche wird es klappen und
damit fangen wir sofort weiter an
und ich hab mir heute also es hat mich
nie überlegt das habe immer wieder eine
schöne zuschauern zugeschickt jo alex
schau dir doch mal bitte an
was sagst du dazu und zwar geht es heute
um die zehn stunden youtube drinnen von
youtube als glaubt die sicherheit auf
deutsche youtube drinnen ja das ist
wirklich sehr interessant und will jetzt
mal schauen wäre so drin ist in dem
ranking gut ich weiß was ist natürlich
immer ein bisschen oberflächlich aber
ich will euch das ganze nur auf
unterhaltsamer basis vorstellen also ich
werde doch gar nicht sagen
die finde ich aber viel schöner dann
wollen auch gar nicht lange lagern wenn
es gefällt das nach oben und wir fangen
ist dann übrigens keine ferien war
bereits andy ferienende in vielen
bundesländern hier in deutschland nur
top 10 schöne youtube trainiert in
meinen zehn schönsten youtube drin also
als kleine info vorweg ich habe das
natürlich nicht erstellt damit es klar
durchführen wir hier an platz den boni
track trace ist ein stück waren es kann
man ja kaum ausrechenbar ist eine schöne
coole deutsche youtube ich glaube die
kenne ich sogar juni träsch dadurch
lässt uns die hat er irgendwie genau der
endlich hier die ganzen drei uhr nachts
videos rufe niemals und jonas irgendwas
zu hause an sagen mir angeschaut
das zeug ich mich jetzt auch gar nicht
weiter zuschauen ja wohl nicht rasch auf
jeden fall super hier rebecca ring sagt
mir auch fest sie ist schön und eine
deutsche youtube in ihr kanal heißt die
bäckerin und dima sportchef meinte wenn
ich diese anzeige prozent macht ihr
gesetz also bei ihr habe ich auf jeden
fall im bild vor augen also hier auf dem
bild aber ich weiß wäre platz im smi
bist du ein kind aber schön 17 jahre alt
und hat schon 25 tausend abonnenten und
lass mich raten dies ebenfalls deutsche
youtube steht am ende die früher hat die
mit ihrer anderen freundin videos
gedreht doch weil die eltern natürlich
erlaubt macht jetzt alleine videos er
gut mit 10 ist es doch immer so eine
sache
also ich finde mit zehn jahren sollte
man jetzt noch nicht unbedingt youtube
videos drehen natürlich ist es jedem
selbst überlassen und wenn die eltern
das okay finde ist das natürlich völlig
ok ich muss mir da hat gut anschauen hat
die enni denn so produziert bei 52.000
abonnenten mit zehn jahren ist natürlich
schon eine krasse leitung gmbh gehören
schon 65 der 6.000 abonnenten hat sie
schon urlaub in spanien
die sommerferien beginnen dies kann
nicht ziehen also ohne witzig wird die
locker so auf 13 14 15 schätzen aber
nicht sehen oder wenn ich jetzt dann
okay sagen wir sie es 13
sie ist zehn jahre alt wenn ich jetzt
dumm oder platin echten lehrer übrigens
dies ausführen und hat total lange haare
wie auch alle anderen user enisa lässt
sie in einen deutlich jüngeren
und jetzt bin ich leider kommt später
bin ich eigentlich auch total schön und
hab total lange haare
doch schon mit 1 6-liter kenne ich muss
ich mir nicht antun
platz julia beauty ist dies nicht ganz
als dieses nicht ganz alt und hat schon
eine million abonnenten dazu ist ja auch
noch schön du hast vergessen dass die
aus deutschland kommt ganz wichtig sie
ist nicht ganz so als sei oder nicht
also da muss ich mir jetzt eigentlich
auch nicht angucken kennen
wahrscheinlich auch viele von euch zu
platzen
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie so hier
das ranking ist ruhe in den letzten
plätzen wäre das gibt als wenn jetzt
hier und da die auf 1 und 2 sind weil
ich wollte keine eigene meinung bremsten
somit nicht sieht auch die 15 und hat
schöne kleidung traum haare und eine
gute figur
missmutig sommer zwar an kenne ich nehme
es nicht mit niki 150 abonnenten ist ja
auch schon mal nicht schlecht koffer
packen für die usa enthält bezahlte vor
mäusen das tue ich mir da nicht weiter
finde ich nicht gut also produkte die
jugend wird auf youtube unter aller
kanone
ich weiß bin ich guten schönes placement
ist mit dabei mit mich hier auf jeden
fall eine sehr hübsche youtube drin und
da sieht man finde ich da passt es so
richtig bis 15
aber nicht so wie unsere die es nicht
sehen verlaufen hoch kuckuck soho lauren
lauren polo zu klaren coco ist auch
wahrscheinlich die tawakkul geschwenkt
hat schöne haare und die perfekt auf
eine super beschreibt nahezu auf 1,2
millionen abonnenten er fast so viel wie
ich ich darf nachts alleine für 500 euro
bei dm stoppen
natürlich auch noch gern lassen sich das
nachts allein für so verwenden
spielwarengeschäfts abmelde
die kenne ich auf jeden fall muss ich
mir gar nicht anschauen von ihr habe ich
auf jeden fall schon mal gehört und ich
glaube da habe ich aus man wieder
gesehen so jetzt wird's spannend ist
militärisch wie sie hat nur 1000
abonnenten
trotzdem eine leistung aber macht so
coole videos unterstützt die dort in dem
ihr abonniert die hersteller habe und
dies perfekt
sie hat oft kleidung aber auch schöne
kleidung an
sie hat offene kleidung ich habe mich
vertraten die kommt nicht aus
deutschland sondern aus der schweiz
besonders schön die dem tausch bei
videos einfach eine wunderschöne frau
jetzt komme ich mir mal in jeans nicht
ob ihr das ist ein verrat an also name
geändert auf jeden fall sympathische
stadt gerecht aber kann sich bis jetzt
noch nicht ist aber jetzt auch nicht so
mein lieblings content pakete auch immer
das eigentlich denkt von meinem
äußerlichen aber ich stelle mir also auf
youtube wächst das war's mit dem video
ich hoffe damit sie auf platz zwei
rangiert auf platz eins baby könnte ja
meinen kommentar schreiben wm findet ihr
besser da die abi oder alle also ich
würde das dritte bildet da ist megaschön
und dazu mega gut die schöne haare blond
und die mega geil aus der kleidung ihre
outfits einfach alles die mega berühmte
youtube in bibi ist der knaller siehst
wunderschön alles ist wunderschön hier
alles denn wie wir und julian das
behindert bin ich rede ja das ist so
viel dazu ich hoffe es hat euch ein
bisschen unterhalten ich weiß es nicht
so das krasseste video aber die krassen
videos werden jetzt folge auf jeden fall
ich fliege jetzt morgen oder übermorgen
nach spanien dort kommt auf jeden fall
auch das ein oder andere klasse video
seit ich beim volkslauf checkt auf jeden
fall special unentdeckt das ist ganz
ganz wichtig wenn ihr mit der jetzt
folgt weil dann seht ihr das so wie ich
im urlaub bin und sonntag und wir sehen
uns am sonntag wieder morgen ist noch
kein video ich muss bisschen produzieren
und so haut rein sonntag skizzen nur auf
keinen fall verpassen
ciao